it's Monday November 6th so it's time
for another monthly update video I'll
talk about what went on in October what
we've got coming up in November first I
want to clue you in as I always do to
three big things coming up for this
month the first of them is its world
philosophy day on the sixteenth
celebrated worldwide it's a UNESCO
series of events and I will be giving a
talk here actually being on a panel here
in Milwaukee and then giving a talk also
in Chicago that night so stay tuned for
that big thing number two we have some
really cool content coming up in our
webinar and online seminars this time
we're talking about Nietzsche birth of
tragedy and responses to life talk about
that more in the November section and
the third big thing that I want to bring
to your attention I've got a new series
of videos coming out I released the
first one yesterday
these are interview videos where I
actually sit down with somebody and
shant about in the world of ideas and
what they're doing with them usually
somebody from philosophy but I might
consider some other things so those are
the three big things all right let's
talk about the month of October a lot of
stuff that went on in in that month in
part because for me as editor of
Stoicism today stoic on stoic context in
Toronto stoic week all of those are
things that I'm involved with they also
get tapped to do a lot of talks
elsewhere you know - they're even
actually still going on in the present
so we had stoic on and that was a huge
event 400 people attended flew up to
Toronto gave my workshop you can see the
link for the video for that in the
description below and it was really
great though very intense alright I got
a lot of conversations both with other
members of you know the team and some of
the other speakers and
with a lot of fans a lot of people who
had showed up some of whom had seen my
videos or read some of my other work and
so that was quite fun late nights every
single night following snowicon' was
stoic on X smaller about 70 or maybe 80
people attended that one that was really
quite fun I didn't have to speak during
that but I did record some things and
while I was there I managed to record
interviews with with quite a few people
and I even created a little video from
stoic on itself just about you know the
buzz that was happening before I
actually left for snowicon' I also had
another session in the worlds of
speculative fiction that that we do here
in Milwaukee it's an ongoing [ __ ] not
quarterly monthly series hosted by the
Brookfield public library and we talked
about a rather lesser-known science
fiction author who deserves a lot of
attention cial Katherine Lucille Moore
so we talked about some of her works
that was a very fun conversation we
actually got to try out a new slightly
upgraded camera and we're still getting
the hang of that I mentioned that there
was you know stoic on after after coming
back from stoic on and stoic on X it was
stoic weak and I gave two different
talks one down at the New Acropolis in
Chicago the video for that will be
coming out fairly soon we also did a
three-person panel for the Mk II stoic
fellowship with myself my wife and
partner Andy shaaka
and Sean Miller one of my friends and
and colleagues from from Marquette
discussing how we apply stoic philosophy
in the workplace so that was pretty cool
stoic week itself was a major success
over 6,000 people participated in it I'm
actually going to include two sets of
talks that I gave in early November in
the October thing right here the
Rockford Universe
he brought me back down again to give a
set of three talks on stoic philosophy
to the students there and in just a meet
and greet with students as well so that
was quite fun two of the talks were ones
that I had given there last year and the
videos for those I recorded last year
but I also recorded a new one
specifically on the metonym met often
vexed I was gonna say many of X but
often a vexed issue of what is this in
accordance with nature that the Stoics
are talking about so I did a little
thing on that I also did a think house
that's with my alma mater Lakeland
University a think house talk up in
Sheboygan just last Thursday at the very
beginning of the month that was one that
was you know quite developed rehearsed
it was about anger and anger management
huh philosophy can help with that so you
should hopefully see that coming out
later this month as well it was a very
busy month for me in terms of teaching
I'm still teaching my to Marquette
classes and we're now knee deep in the
part where there's a lot of grading for
me to do and students are starting to
you know you know it's a long march
through through this ethic stuff that I
think some of the students are starting
to get a little bit bogged down I also
started teaching my Marist class world
views and values by the way if you're
interested in seeing a similar version
one that I used to teach of that class
and you'd like to take it yourself you
can find it my teachable Academy it's
not exactly the same as what we're doing
in the Mayoress classes but it's got a
lot of the same components study a
number of really important philosophers
so that's what's going on as far as
teaching I was trying to get some
writing done I didn't get that much done
on my blog work or book writing work but
understandably so it did get a lot of
editing work done with stoicism today
and solicited a lot of articles so I'm
quite happy about where that is going
and I shot a number of videos I
mentioned that one of the big things as
I started this news
series of interview videos and I'm gonna
hopefully continue that with some people
here in the local area I managed to get
some sit downs while I was at stoic on
with Travis iam the the founder of the
applying stoicism project with pewter
Stan cuit I'm sure I'm butchering his
name because I always do but I did get
an interview with him he's a member of
the the applying or he's a member of the
modern stoicism team and I also got to
sit down with Donald Robertson and so I
think there's a lot of people who are
gonna be eagerly awaiting that I'm
hoping to do some more possibly this
month with with some people in various
venues that I know of so but I don't
want to make any promises about that
lest they not come true right away I
also started another news series book
reviews I call them Sadler's honest book
reviews because that is the aim behind
them to present a sort of objective
unvarnished view on these books that are
either about philosophy and life or
about say management and leadership or
or about other things where the world of
ideas is intersecting with the world of
practice so I started out with William
for rylos book and and I'm gonna be
doing many more of those I didn't get
all six of my half-hour Haegele videos I
got five of them done this month rather
than six so I'm always a little bit sad
about that but five is good and I shot a
number of other core concept videos that
I think you may have seen released those
core concept videos on Cicero's work as
well as the the event videos so a lot of
stuff going on in addition to that you
know I continued with coaching I
continued with with a lot of tutorial
sessions picked up a couple new
philosophical counseling clients so a
lot of work in in the month of October
and it set me behind a little bit now
let's talk about
November we're already almost a week
into it and and I mentioned that several
of the events are already past but we
have a lot of cool stuff coming up this
month if you're around tomorrow Tuesday
November 7th in this area at 6 p.m. at
the Frank Weinberg library in Mequon I
am going to be giving another one of the
Philosopher's in the midst of history
talks this one is going to be on
Friedrich Nietzsche the apex of the West
and the threat of niall ISM so that is a
do not miss if you're in the area a
little bit later in the week November
9th that's Thursday 7 o'clock p.m.
Brookfield Public Library we're gonna be
doing the worlds of speculative fiction
for this month and we're talking about L
Sprague de Kampf and the complete
enchanter series of books where by using
symbolic logic people find themselves in
another universe well a whole bunch of
universes so that's going to be a lot of
fun then the next week after that
November 13th
11:00 a.m. to 11:45 online we have our
free webinar and this one this this
month is it's a lot of nature this month
Nietzsche on the three noble responses
to life that is going to be about the
birth of tragedy and the DNA cn the
Apollonian and the Socratic as noble
responses to life then on world
philosophy day November 16th we've got
two events in two different locations
here in Milwaukee actually in Bayview
the Bayview neighborhood at the Bayview
public library 12:30 to 1:30 we're going
to be having a hosted world philosophy
day panel discussion about philosophy in
real life then I'm driving down to
Chicago to the New Acropolis where Jalal
and I will be presenting five Socratic
approaches to chasing happiness another
world philosophy day event that's going
to be a lot of fun I think and then
finishing out that week that Saturday
November 18th we have our online
intensive seminars these are also on
each on three noble responses to life
but these are going to be much more
in-depth much more time for Q&A and
discussion those are at 10 o'clock a.m.
Central Time running at 12 o'clock and 4
o'clock
running to 6 o'clock then the week well
actually it looks like we have a little
bit of a break November 25th from 2 to 3
we have our patreon supporter philosophy
chant this is for people at a certain
level of support by the way if you like
the work I do a lot of nice perks if you
sign up and become a patreon supporter
including getting to participate in this
unstructured open-ended philosophy chat
November 29th from 5 to 6 p.m. that's a
Wednesday we'll have our half-hour
Haegele online Q&A and discussion
session and then we finish up on
November 30th the very last day of the
month from 6:00 to 7:00 Shorewood Public
Library with the MKE stoic fellowship
meeting so a lot of stuff going on I
haven't even mentioned the philosophy
pop ups which of course you want to stay
tuned to my social media for unless you
become a patreon supporter because they
already know when they're happening this
month but if everybody else will find
out the day of the pop ups those are
proving quite quite popular what else
have we got going on well I should talk
about I should mention the fact that in
addition to teaching and doing the
philosophical counseling and all and
also doing some consulting and and what
else coaching and tutoring one of the
other things I'll be doing a bit more of
this month is going on podcasts
I'm already lined up with three
appointments over the month for three
different podcasts all of them new to me
yes and the two of them are new to me
and I'm gonna be going back on death
hangout with Oliver and Keith there was
a lot of fun so and I made be doing some
others so you should probably stay tuned
to that those will probably be coming
out towards the
end of the month what else do I need to
tell you about videos right
what do we've got coming up this month
with videos so I'm gonna try to get back
to doing some of the Sadler's soapbox
videos I might be doing a philosophy and
current events video fairly soon it's a
matter of carving out the time for it
of course you'll see the events videos
for all of these events the interview
videos are coming up and I'm gonna be
doing some more Sadler's honest book
reviews but I'm also gonna be doing some
some more of course half hour Hegel
turns out that we're a little bit behind
in releasing some of these half hour
hanging but I've got to shoot some new
half hour Hegel and I've got a number of
other Cicero core concepts on Cicero's
on duties to do this month if I get
finished with those then I also have
lined up to do some stuff on Heidegger's
being in time introduction I know some
people have been looking forward to that
so that's already a ton of stuff we'll
see how much of it I can actually
accomplish the one thing I also do want
to mention as we're moving towards the
end of the year we are starting to fill
up the calendar with events we've been
in conversation with a number of
institutions and libraries and and
departments about where precisely I'll
be speaking in you know quarter one
quarter two of next year so if you're
interested in having me come and talk to
your institution group organization
whatever it happens to be or if you're
independently wealthy you want somebody
to do a private talk for you that you
want to put on for your friends I'm game
for that as well just email me at Greg
entries in i/o calm and we'll be happy
to to talk with you about about any of
that the as many of you know I have a
wide range of things that I can talk
about and I'm practically interested in
almost anything you can bring to my
attention so that's enough of that
hope all of you have a great month look
at the links below you can see any of
the stuff that you missed or any of the
stuff that you might want to put on your
calendar and I hope to see some of you
either face-to-face or in our online
events
you